[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez y nuestro tema de
análisis en esta ocasión es Haití que
enfrenta una crisis humanitaria con
escasez de alimentos o combustible y
agua que provocan un hambre catastrófica
en ese contexto es que el gobierno
emitió su solicitud de ayuda militar del
exterior el detonante de la actual
crisis es el bloqueo de una de las
terminales clave de combustible por
parte de bandas armadas un bloqueo que
comenzó en septiembre y que provocó
escasez de gasolina y diesel lo que
detuvo la mayor parte del transporte y
lo que a su vez generó escasez de bienes
básicos incluida el agua potable vamos a
conversar sobre esta problemática y para
ello hemos invitado a Robinson
escritora haitiano analista político y
activista por los Derechos Humanos quien
nos atiende desde Rosario en Argentina y
también desde Barcelona en España el
doctor Luis de Jean Pierre logiston
doctor en ciencia política y
Administración pública ambos doy gracias
por estar con nosotros y a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
son parte del debate dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el debate f24 y Ángel hago
f24 la etiqueta es numeral el debate f24
y no olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y también en TuneIn
comenzamos primero con un poco de
contexto sobre lo que ha sucedido en los
últimos días en Haití el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU debate sobre la
posible intervención militar o
solicitada por el país con esta nación
subida en una profunda crisis y bajo El
dominio de bandas criminales se enfrenta
también un brote de cólera veamos más en
el siguiente informe
la extrema crisis social política
sanitaria y de seguridad de Haití genera
divisiones en la ONU Estados Unidos y
México Proponen dos resoluciones ante el
Consejo de Seguridad una para sancionar
a los responsables de la crisis y otra
con el fin de permitir la intervención
de fuerzas internacionales
la segunda resolución en la que estamos
trabajando autorizaría una misión de
asistencia de seguridad internacional
ajenal ONU para ayudar a mejorar la
situación de seguridad
China y Rusia se mostraron reticentes a
enviar una misión extranjera para el
momento en que un gobierno haitiano
elige enviar una fuerza de acción rápida
Haití esperamos recibir la comprensión y
el apoyo de las partes de Haití o
enfrentará resistencia o incluso
provocará confrontación violenta de la
población en el país miles de ciudadanos
salieron a las calles para rechazar la
posible intervención también para pedir
la renuncia del Primer Ministro Ariel
quien días atrás solicitó ayuda
internacional para controlar la
situación en el país actualmente la
capital Puerto Príncipe y otras zonas
están bajo dominio de bandas criminales
estas dificultan tanto la entrada de
suministros como de ayuda médica en un
momento en el que la nación vive un
rebrote de cólera que ha dejado decenas
de Muertos
[Música]
hoy Ariel Henry hace un llamado a las
fuerzas internacionales para que pongan
un pie en la tierra de yang de salim
Permítame darles una lista de todas las
veces que Estados Unidos los
imperialistas estadounidenses hicieron
eso
eh Le pedí a Alice a Mary Kate Y es que
en el pasado una misión de la ONU la
minuta causó múltiples conflictos en el
país desde un brote de cólera que mató a
10.000 personas pero también acusaciones
de violaciones a niños y adultos entre
otros escándalos
Pues bien vamos ahora con las preguntas
correspondientes a esta conversación o
sobre la crisis de que vive Haití y para
ello quisiera empezar con el señor
Robinson glecible quien tiene el rol de
activista en esta charla Robinson
Mientras que el gobierno de Ariel Henry
emitió un llamado a que la comunidad
internacional intervenga hay protestas
en el país y sectores de la ciudadanía
que aseguran que no quieren una
intervención y que eso no es lo que
necesita Haití En qué se sustenta esa
postura Y qué es lo que necesita según
estos sectores
y es muy buenas tardes creo que mi
posición siempre con respecto a la
situación que está viviendo mi país
siempre es muy muy clara en este
contexto digo no
cualquier tipo de fuerza de ocupación
cualquier tipo de intervención militar
en haitismo a lo largo de la historia y
la historia es testigo del fracaso de
las fuerzas de intervención militar en
Haití Por ejemplo si empezamos por
ejemplo del año 1993 hasta el día de hoy
son 10
misiones por ejemplo de las Naciones
Unidas de Haití resultados siempre un
fracaso
o sea en el resultado en el terreno del
país no no no no hemos visto nada por
era que mató a más de 10.000 personas y
ahora tenemos
dejó las fuerzas de ocupación de la ONU
yolaciones mujeres embarazadas Entonces
no no ahí no no necesitan hay no
necesitaba una fuerza extranjera militar
para solucionar ningún tipo de problema
porque esas fuerzas en realidad no fue
la solución al problemas lo que sí
necesita este gobierno de facto de
justamente es mantenerse en el poder
porque con una ayuda de una fuerza
militar extranjera eso lo va a pasar más
tiempo en el poder y a la víctima
siempre va a ser el pueblo haitiado la
población haitiana que está sufriendo
hace años y años
doctor Jean Pierre Cuál es su opinión y
un saludo para ustedes bienvenido a este
debate de Francia 24 gracias Un saludo
muy caluroso a mi compatriota o Benson
mira lo que compartió acaba de decir es
cierto lo que pasa todas las personas
que encuentren la comunidad
internacional los interlocutores que
tienen la comunidad internacional en el
país
y uno mira los últimos 10 años estas
personas no tuvieron ninguna relación no
tiene ninguna representación electoral
con el pueblo
una fuerza de ocupación al país
normalmente la historia misma del país
nos dice que esta fuerza de ocupación lo
único que vienen a hacer es agarrar la
situación de dominación que tiene la
oligarquía la orilla los obligacos los
ricos los más claros son estas personas
que ellos vienen a proteger Por ejemplo
si uno mira los Estados Unidos para
resolver el problema de las inseguridad
tratar de castigar a los responsables de
de la situación en Haití supuestamente
quitan las visas de estas personas que
son responsables eso lo veo como un
insulto a la inteligencia de nosotros
como intelectuales sabemos que la
99% de los jefes que propagan
perdemos por un momento la comunicación
con el doctor Jean Pierre y mientras
tanto pues ese Robinson conversemos
nosotros lo cierto Es que en los últimos
días empecé al rechazo de la población
el gobierno de Joe biden redactó una
resolución de la ONU para el despliegue
de una llamada fuerza de acción rápida
esta resolución se está discutiendo en
el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU y
además ya fue enviada una delegación de
respuesta a desastres por parte de
Estados Unidos diríamos a evaluar En qué
estado se encuentra Haití una de las
conclusiones es que puede haber cientos
de contagios de cólera por decirlo menos
pero Comencemos hablando de esa fuerza
de acción rápida en qué consistiría una
nueva intervención podría algo
diferenciarla de estas otras
intervenciones que usted no nos
mencionado al principio del programa
lo que sí pasa siempre es que la única
opción de Estados Unidos a las
respuestas o a sus intentos de de
solución a las dificultades o a lo
pruebas de Haití son siempre esto una
fuerza de ocupación es mandar militares
O sea no tienen otra opción es mandar un
ejército lo que pasa es que justamente
los nombres cambian los nombres de las
misiones cambian pero es la misma
realidad tiene el mismo objetivo y al
objetivo más que nada No es no es la
protección de la población haitiana lo
voy a repetir esas misiones no tienen
como objetivos la proyección de la
población haitiana siempre sí se habla
el nombre de la población haitiana pero
en realidad lo que se hace se pone todo
el pueblo haitiano está al margen el
pueblo haitiano está afuera de todas
esas conversaciones justamente
en la historia reciente de de de mi país
es traducido siempre ha estado en Haití
Así que para mí siempre me causa
bastante gracia no como que a veces la
gente piensa que Estados Unidos está muy
muy ajeno de lo que está pasando en
Haití No hoy en día los dirigentes
haitianos si lo puedes llamar así entre
comillas no las grandes decisiones en
Haití nos están tomadas por la clase
política interna son decisiones de la
comunidad internacional por ejemplo este
gobierno que tenemos hoy en día es un
gobierno impuesto por la comunidad
internacional es un gobierno sin
legitimidad sin apoyo popular el único
apoyo que tiene este gobierno es la
comunidad internacional es justamente
una fuerza en Haití en este momento
tiene solamente ese objetivo entonces me
queda perfectamente Clara su postura
frente a la posibilidad de una
intervención extranjera que entonces
según su opinión sería lo que
necesitaría Haití en este momento porque
es una serie de tragedias que se van
acumulando en la última década por no
decir más y en este momento tenemos como
resultado no solamente el país más pobre
de América Latina sino con una cantidad
de problemas de toda índole y este
episodio de las pandillas es apenas el
último es consecuencia de de Como le
digo de muchos conflictos que vienen
desde antes que se puede hacer
justamente el problema de Haití No es
algo metafísico que de fechas tiene
nombres y tiene responsables es
justamente para sacar a mi país este
pozo muy profundo es lo digo Siempre es
un acuerdo político a pesar de todo es
un acuerdo político para sacar Haití en
ese Abismo porque justamente ninguna
ninguna fuerza extranjera ningún país
entre comillas amigo de Haití nos van a
sacar de esa situación la solución
depende de las fuerzas vivas de la
nación haitiana es mi postura
bueno y Mientras tanto en el último año
pues hemos visto hasta el asesinato de
un presidente Entonces
en este punto ni siquiera está claro que
va a pasar con las elecciones tenemos un
gobierno interino en el país a bloqueos
de República Dominicana que está parando
Desde allí la migración que intenta
precisamente llegar hacia Estados Unidos
en una situación desesperada que
perspectiva ve usted en la posibilidad
de que existan elecciones
por ahora no veo una una posibilidad de
organizar elecciones ya mismo porque
justamente este gobierno actual este
gobierno actual no tiene esa prioridad
su prioridad no es organizar elecciones
justamente es mantenerse lo más tiempo
posible es jugar con el tiempo
Lamentablemente lo digo Siempre el
cinismo el cinismo del político haitiano
es algo muy muy muy muy muy muy muy frío
es muy triste lamentable lo digo así
porque justamente Un gobierno Un
gobierno con una legitimidad popular Un
gobierno con un poquito de sensibilidad
podía justamente mirar lo que está
pasando en este país cómo cómo cómo cómo
puedes imaginar en un país cuando la
gente de la población sale a protestar
este mismo gobierno usa las fuerzas
locales para reprimir a esta población
que está pidiendo una sola cosa queremos
respirar queremos vivir entonces es
cuando alguien me pregunta por ejemplo
cuando va vamos a hacer elecciones no se
puede organizar elecciones en esa
situación no se puede organizar
elecciones con un grupo de gente que no
tiene legitimidad por eso un acuerdo
social un acuerdo político con Justo con
el acuerdo con la sociedad civil sea
justo esto que puedes sacar el país un
poquito de este lío que estamos viviendo
hace años ciegos no es algo que va a
pasar el problema es tan complejo no es
algo que se puede solucionar en un año
ni en algunos países sean justamente
mucha gente piensa eso Bueno vamos a
Haití vamos a cambiar las cosas ya no
aquí tienes un ritmo ahí te tiene su
tiempo y hay que respetarlo bien
entonces con nuestros invitados estamos
o están más bien los dos de acuerdo en
que una fuerza de acción rápida o una
intervención internacional no sería la
respuesta sino que viene desde adentro y
ya que recuperamos la comunicación con
el doctor Horizon quisiera invitarlo
para que nos diga Cuál es su opinión a
ese respecto sobre una posibilidad de un
acuerdo político instaurado por la
sociedad civil porque es que no se ve
por dónde hay un espacio democrático
para abrir en todo este conflicto
por supuesto la sociedad civil tiene que
jugar su papel en este acuerdo pero el
problema es que los que están
actualmente que supuestamente que
represente a la sociedad civil no tiene
legitimidad Durante los los últimos
10-15 años esas personas nunca han
tenido un contacto como como si fuera
como una elección que fueron senadores
que fueron tal cosa Ellos nunca
estuvieron una en una elección por eso
mismo estas personas solamente puede
funcionar durante incertidumbre en el
país donante del cabo es la única manera
que ellos pueden tener El Poder bueno Y
mientras tanto está el vacío político
que dejó el fallecimiento de yo en el
movies hay alguna manera de retomar
te retomar otro camino para Haití porque
claro están los dos de acuerdo en que
hay un problema con digamos la clase
política de ti en este momento pero hay
una salida para que esto cambie al menos
en el mediano plazo pero el problema es
que las las posiciones del Internacional
las posiciones del internacionales
imponer a Haití desde unos dirigentes
Entonces qué pasa estas mismas personas
que participan en la destrucción del
país son estas mismas personas que la
misma comunidad internacional está
imponiendo está poniendo en el poder en
el país entonces así mismo el país nunca
va a desarrollar porque estas personas
han participado en unos en unas cosas
muy muy muy muy muy muy
de corrupción o en unas actos de
corrupción muy duro cualquier
estabilidad cualquier democracia
cualquier justicia esta persona no van a
aceptar esto porque ellos tienen que
rendir cuentas
regresó a usted el gobierno asegura que
los problemas están dados por cuenta de
las plantillas que crearon todo este
caos en Puerto Príncipe con las batallas
callejeras que incendiaron barrios que
secuestraron el flujo del combustible en
el país por no decir pues todas las
demás vejaciones secuestro y asesinato
de personas no funcionan los hospitales
no funcionan los centros educativos sin
posibilidad de reabastecerse con
combustible y con energía Por qué se
desató en este momento de la historia la
violencia de pandillas en Haití
bien el tema de las violencias de las
pandillas en Haití No es algo que viene
de hace unos meses desde hace años por
ejemplo en el transcurso de la historia
de Haití los políticos haitianos con la
mayoría tienen una Esa esa esa Esa esa
Esa esa
mala costumbre
esa posición cínica de convivencia con
grupos armados justamente para poder
controlar cuando hay elecciones al
grupos por ejemplo en el sector
económico que tiene sus intereses en
esas en esos grupos armados por ejemplo
cuando hay protestas en el país A veces
usan los políticos usan a esos grupos
para reprimir a las protestas populares
usan a la policía local de manera
oficial y usted a los grupos armados
para reprimir a las poblaciones para no
protestar ahora lo que Es que hoy en día
un descontrol de estos grupos armados
casi los políticos no tienen el mismo
control que tenían antes hacia Esas
personas son como ahora grupos
independientes entre comillas la
situación se ha vuelto muy complicada y
ahora es muy muy difícil llegar a
controlar a esas bandas armadas que
están teorizando a la población haitiana
lo que lo que voy a repetir puede ser
algo utópico pero un acuerdo político y
lo que digo lo los sostengo un acuerdo
político entre todos los sectores que
manejan la clase política alterna puede
en un momento calmar a esos grupos
armados Porque si entramos en la vida
política haitiana casi
por lo menos un policía no tiene
contacto directo con Los jefes de esas
bandas armadas Así que ellos mismos son
grupos políticos los grupos económicos
que manejan el país pueden entrar en
negociación entre comillas para poder
calmar
la la la reacción de esos grupos
armados que están interiorizando a la
población haitiana doctor son Usted cree
que sí es posible que un eventual pacto
social pudiera calmar la violencia de
las pandillas
eso es una buena pregunta es una buena
pregunta pero lo que pasa una un acuerdo
social con quién lo que pasa es que la
hay muchos intelectuales en Haití hay
muchos políticos honestos Pero los
bandidos que supuestamente que son
políticos que no tiene contacto con el
pueblo que no tiene afiliación con el
pueblo esas personas hacen todo posible
para intimidar a esas personas para que
si viven en el país no se meten en la
política si viven en el exterior no
pueden egresar para meterse en la
política para para cambiar las cosas eso
es yo no veo yo no veo un acuerdo fácil
porque sobre todo si uno mira la
comunidad internacional con quién se
están uniendo con los mismos que
representan el problema en el país
hablemos o más del gobierno de Estados
Unidos al principio del programa
mencionábamos que hay cientos de casos
sospechosos de cólera esto verificado
precisamente por el gobierno de la Casa
Blanca señor que se predice que puede
pasar en las condiciones actuales Haití
ni siquiera ha podido recuperarse de los
terremotos y Huracanes de los últimos
tiempos y ahora estos cientos de casos
sospechosos pues son resultado de que no
hay manera de medir qué es lo que
realmente está pasando porque los
hospitales están sin poder funcionar A
toda máquina
es una sociedad disfuncional o sea en un
país normal donde un sistema de
seguridad social donde a hospitales que
está funcionando lo del caso de los
correas que esté de la corredera que
estamos hablando en Haití es como si
fuera es como si fuera un gripe pero no
es un caso que debería ser tanto lo que
pasa la fragilidad del sistema de salud
que es inexistente hace que la cosa se
ve más grave pero no vamos a decir para
combatir
cólera se necesita una intervención
militar o se necesita médicos y
medicamentos o sistemas de salud Por qué
una intervención militar eso es lo que
tenemos que acentuarnos el Por qué
significa esta solicitud de Haití para
una intervención militar para ayudar Es
para proteger a los intereses de los que
gobiernan en contra el pueblo y mientras
tanto para nuestro otro invitado para
Robinson pues ya sabemos también que
Canadá y Estados Unidos están en el
proceso de envío de vehículos armados
Para apoyar a la policía de Haití esto
servirá de algo
yo quería que sí servís si asisten por
ejemplo en Estados Unidos
pero estamos ya tiene que disolver su
problema de pandillas pero estancias no
puede resolver un problema de pandilla
en Haití estas asistencias sí pueden
ayudar pero hay otros países que pueden
ayudar porque solamente Estados Unidos
en Canadá será que ellos tienen algunos
intereses que están protegiendo porque
otros países no pueden ir también ayudar
en Haití hay países que tienen más
afinidades con nosotros que Estados
Unidos y Canadá por ejemplo hay países
que tiene una comunidad muy grande de
negros que comparten primero por la
apariencia y culturalmente Y por qué
esos países no porque Canadá y Estados
Unidos Sí y eso es lo que uno tiene que
sospechar será que ellos tienen alguna
cosa que están protegiendo en Haití y
cosas se han dicho cosas se han visto
los últimos 15 años en Haití Cómo se ha
creado las pandillas
Robinson no es su opinión
bien Es que justamente algunos países
estos países estadounidos y por ejemplo
piensa que con más armas se puede
solucionar la cuestión de inseguridad
que esa atravesando el pueblo yo diría
primero que Estados Unidos se por una
muestra de buena voluntad de tratar
primero de frenar el tráfico de armas
que sale de Estados Unidos para llegar a
Haití me parece esto sería una decisión
muy muy interesante Porque esos grupos
armados que viven en varios vulnerados
como llegan a tener armas por ejemplo
que salen 5000 dólares son armas de
fabricación es estadounidense solida
primero que esos países si quieren y
realmente colaborar con Haití se cree
realmente ayudar a Haití es tratar de
frenar ese tráfico de armas que salen
desde su país para entrar en Haití ahí
sí diría que hago una muestra de buena
voluntad para poder ayudar el tema de la
inseguridad porque justamente con más
armas no se va a solucionar el problema
de inseguridad no pasa por ahí bien y
ahora volviendo al doctor loriston lo
que sí se ha visto en los últimos meses
y lo hemos conversado en previos debates
es una firme y evidente posición de
Estados Unidos que busca fortalecer más
que nunca las relaciones con América
Latina lo hemos visto con visitas
diplomáticas en los últimos meses en los
últimos meses a varios países de la
región ahora usted me estaba diciendo
que hay intereses que intervienen en
estas actitudes hacia Haití porque hay
como se beneficia Estados Unidos si
logra hacer esta intervención de acción
rápida
muy importante mira en 1914 en 1914 unos
de la fuerza especial de Estados Unidos
marineros antes la intervención de 1915
antes de la ocupación de Haití una cosa
Una curiosidad Los Marineros o los
Marines devan en Haití lo primero que
hicieron saquearon o yo digo saquear
ellos en este momento era para proteger
la finanzas del país ellos sacan todas
las reservas de oro que tenía el país
supuestamente que había posibilidad de
guerra civil como mataron al presidente
que estaba de turno en esta época por
eso mismo yo siempre digo a la gente
mira lo que pasó en 1914 para entender
lo que está pasando hoy y justamente
después de que saquearon el banco de la
República Boom ocupación americana en
Haití de 1915 A 1934 e incluso cambiaron
la constitución del país para des al
campesino De su tierra ahora bien qué
está pasando Ellos tienen aliados tanto
Estados Unidos como Canadá eso no es una
un secreto Ellos tienen muchos intereses
en recursos cursos naturales que están
en Haití Pero hay una cosa que también
que se ha dicho yo no sé qué países yo
no puedo afirmar pero en muchos sitios
donde están las pandillas controlando
muchos de esos sitios sobre todo por el
lado adecuado buque para ir en estas
montañas hay muchos recursos naturales y
la gente que digan en estos sitios
muchas veces ven unos coches muy raros
no se puede decir que son coches de
Estados Unidos porque me entienden pero
son coches con placas diplomáticas que
han entrado en esos sitios entonces uno
se pregunta qué interés tienen para para
para que Haití siempre está bajo la
dominación de ellos por ejemplo el
dinero de la construcción después del
terremoto
ahí sí sigue igual o peor cuando pasó el
terremoto dónde está este dinero
supuestamente la fundación de un
presidente de Estados Unidos estaba
gestionando este dinero que ha pasado
con la destrucción de Haití
Y bueno ya un poco más para ampliar este
este tema acerca de la intervención de
Estados Unidos Robinson Usted qué opina
de los anuncios hechos en los últimos
días por la administración
estadounidense en la que pretende
disminuir los flujos migratorios por la
frontera a Estados Unidos y una de las
estrategias es incluir unas 20.000 visas
temporales de las cuales podrán ser
beneficiados
ciudadanos haitianos puede tener digamos
argumento esta intervención también para
disminuir los flujos migratorios dando
una sensación de más seguridad en Haití
la entrega la entrega o el anuncio de
entrega de Divisas temporales por
Estados Unidos Haití No es algo nuevo se
hace casi todos los años he estado
subiendo este necesita y y
manos de obra barata para para sus
empresas de vez en cuando
entregan visados de trabajo a varios
haitianos pero lo que sí eso no va a
frenar la cantidad de haitianos que
desean dejar el país por esa situación
de inseguridad de pobreza para poder
llegar a las fronteras de Estados Unidos
mira lo que pasó hace algunos meses el
trato que yo la policía estadounidense a
esos miles y miles de haitianos que
estaban en la frontera de Estados Unidos
con México ese trato inhumano o sea no
hubo ninguna voluntad para recibir a los
migrantes haitianos y ya sabemos esa de
la comunidad internacional hay migrantes
que están bien bienvenidos y algunos
migrantes que no y Haití hace parte de
esos países donde los migrantes
haitianos no están Bienvenidos en varios
países en el mundo incluso Estados
Unidos así que esa Promesa de Visas es
para entre comillas mostrar una señal de
buena voluntad pero ya sabemos que ese
que se en vez de una ciudad de buena
voluntad es una señal de hipocresía
enorme
y todo esto en un complejo internacional
mucho
mucho más fuerte porque se da esto en el
contexto de la Guerra de Ucrania que
concentra en este momento todos los
esfuerzos internacionales mientras
estaba aconteciendo la Guerra de Ucrania
también se está discutiendo actualmente
en Naciones Unidas la posibilidad de
enviar estos apoyos que ha pedido el
gobierno de Haití
realmente habrá alguien que pueda
concentrar su atención en su país
teniendo en cuenta todo lo que está
pasando a nivel global
por eso por eso digo Siempre es que el
destino de Haití depende del pueblo
hallado usted ha mencionado claramente
el tema de Ucrania y luego claramente
toda la ayuda que recibe Ucrania como
los países recibían a los migrantes
ucranianos y del otro lado como reciben
por ejemplo en Estados Unidos a los
migrantes haitiados justamente ahí
existe doble moral doble discurso Aurora
de recibir a ciertas personas Bueno
un momento porque decía Estados Unidos
que este plan es de nuevo migratorio que
acaban de lanzar bajo la administración
de Joe biden está basado en el plan
migratorio homólogo de Unidos por
Ucrania
como si fuera un tratamiento igual
Sí justamente hay que decirlo es el es
el racismo lamentablemente que existe en
nuestro mundo porque justamente un
migrante haitiano no tiene el mismo peso
neto su valor que un inmigrante
ucraniano el pasaporte haitiado no tiene
el mismo peso no tiene el mismo valor
que un pasaporte de alguien de Ucrania y
justamente
varios la administración estadounidense
siempre lo ha dicho Incluso el ex
presidente Donald Trump ha tratado de
Haití como no voy a repetir la expresión
pero trato Haití como en países no sé es
no los que viven en Haití No son seres
humanos Entonces si nosotros como
haitianos nos vemos esa voluntad de
poder ayudar a nuestro país de poder ver
el bien de los países nadie lo va a
hacer por nosotros o sea la la solución
de Haití No va a venir del exterior y
también algo muy muy importante la la
historia de Haití tiene un peso
histórico muy muy fuerte porque en la
cabeza de esos grupos internacionales de
la comunidad internacional Haití nunca
debe ser un ejemplo en este mundo Haití
nunca debe ser un ejemplo en este mundo
por sobrevolución por su independencia
es algo que vamos a seguir pagando hasta
no sé qué años porque Haití hizo algo
que cambio radicalmente la historia de
la humanidad Así que pueblos haiteros
nosotros tenemos que estar muy atento de
los asuntos históricos la historia de
Haití No es no es algo del pasado
nuestra historia sigue algo vigente Y es
muy muy presente Por eso tenemos que
reconocer quién está con nosotros
realmente
y Señor loriston por favor sus
conclusiones
las conclusiones que si Estados Unidos o
la comunidad internacional quiere frenar
la violencia en Haití primero hay que
aplicar el artículo cual 149 de la
constitución del país que un Primer
Ministro para llevar el país a la
selecciones segundo Yo pienso que
Estados Unidos tendría que atacar a los
grupos sobre todo la cabeza de los que
fomentan la violencia en Haití por
ejemplo los oligarcos hay unos
expresidentes hay unos oficiales del
gobierno y senadores policía jueces son
ellos que fomentan la violencia porque
ellos benefician de esa violencia Porque
la única manera que ellos pueden vivir
puede pueden tener El Poder en Haití es
por medio de la estabilidad el por medio
de la violencia cada uno tiene su propio
pandilla es así que ellos pueden
mantenerse en el poder porque no tienen
una presentación electoral en el país
muy bien una rápida de radiografía Ya
llegamos al final desde programa y un
agradecimiento para nuestros invitados
las bandas haitianas han ampliado su
control del territorio en Haití Y estos
fortaleció o se empeoró más bien desde
el asesinato del presidente de jovenel
es muy en el 2021 y hay un vacío de
poder un país que además no tiene
parlamento y en el que no se ven
próximas unas elecciones para reemplazar
a este gobierno interino muchas gracias
a ustedes por estar con nosotros
continuaremos informando sigan en
Francia 24
[Música]